just four days and a few critical
headlines after launching the
Conservatives election manifesto Theresa
May has an answer there will now be an
absolute limit on how much people have
to pay for their social care the Prime
Minister said the amount of the cap has
not yet been decided and it will be
subject to a consultation she denied
however that today's announcement Imagi
to a u-turn nothing has changed nothing
has changed
we are offering a long-term solution for
the sustainability of Social Care for
the future we are ensuring that people
older people will not have to worry they
will be able to ensure that their care
whether it's in the home or for them to
go into a home is being paid for and
they won't have to worry about those
bills month after month after month and
they will have the confidence of knowing
that they can pass a hundred thousand
pounds of savings on to their children
nothing has changed well Prime
Minister's denials of a u-turn came
despite this response given by the
Health Secretary Jeremy Hunt in a radio
interview last Thursday when he was
asked about a cap not only are we
dropping it but we are dropping it ahead
of a general election and we're being
completely explicit in our manifesto
that we're dropping it and we're
dropping it because we've looked again
at this proposal and we don't think it's
fair also Steve Webb is director of
policy at the raw London the country's
largest mutual insurer and he was a
liberal Democrat pensions minister in
the coalition government he joins us now
from Leeds via Skype so Steve very good
evening to you first of all are you
clear this is a u-turn I think it is as
you just broadcast Jeremy Hunt was
saying that they decided a cap wasn't
fair but what's the become apparent is
that if you have a relatively valuable
house you could end up paying hundreds
of thousands of pounds before you're
down to the hundred thousand limits at
which point State help was going to cut
it so I think they've realized that was
toxic and I've had to reintroduce the
idea of a cap as well as their other
proposal now the cap of course was first
proposed by Sir Andrew dill not when he
did an investigation on this for the
coalition government why do you think
mrs. May ruled it out it's rather
strange really because surrender Dylan's
not a party politics she's a very
Chaffee consulted lots of people over a
period of years there's lots of debate
and what's really worrying is when
something like that that carefully
thought through a legislative plan gets
replaced by something but I think was
written pretty quickly and has already
started to unravel so actually long term
social care needs long term solutions
and the worry is if these things are
rewritten very quickly people just won't
know where they stand now one of the
things that Sir Andrew do not
recommended was that in addition to a
cap you'd have an market developing with
insurers stepping in to cover unexpected
costs is this a market you think insures
a king to tap in theory it should be
because we've got a rapidly aging
population we've got huge amounts of
housing wealth amongst all the people
and the risk of catastrophic care costs
put that together that ought to make for
an insurance market the big missing link
has been insurers would be covering what
the state's doesn't because the state
has been so uncertain about what it's
going to cover insurers almost can't
design a product to fill those gaps
because they don't know what the gaps
are so I guess it depends on where the
cap is set that's going to be pretty
crucial well it is I mean if this is a
sort of holding position through the
election and the cappings are really
very very high then most people could
still pay a huge amount of money in care
costs I suspect if this all goes ahead
the camp will be high because otherwise
it costs a lot of money to have a cap it
cost money to add but under those
threshold and this measure will actually
end up costing money rather than saving
it so how much do you think this
backtrack is actually going to cost
taxpayers I mean I've seen figures of
two billion pounds or more being bandied
around is is that the sort of number you
arrive at given the numbers of all the
people the aging of the population over
time we could be talking serious so many
hundreds of millions or more the crucial
question of course is where might the
cap be and that the dilemma is we're
going to have angels on a pinhead here
it's not going to be the deal not cap
which was just your social care costs so
you weren't capped us all on your board
and lodging costs which are a big part
of the bill maybe this will be a total
care cost cap but you know how people
are supposed to plan at the moment I
really don't know I mean isn't there a
case for just saying we should socialize
all of these costs anyway I mean the
sums being banded around is still a drop
in the ocean compared with say the
entire budget for the National Health
Service well certainly if
has catastrophic health costs you know
needs heart bypass surgery or something
incredibly expensive then the NHS is
there for all of us we pool that risk
that's not the case with social care and
Raziel nots argument is this is the last
unpooled risk and whether it's private
insurance or social insurance
this really is an insurance issue we're
not going to all save enough to just on
the off chance we spend hundreds of
thousands and care you should find
somewhere pooling this risk and briefly
Steve I mean a lot of people will say
you should never do a u-turn II for your
politician but because Theresa May done
the right thing in backtracking do you
feel I think the pressure was just
becoming overwhelming that the polls
were moving dramatically and I think
because the Conservatives had so long
been the party of homeownership under
the inheritance and this policy seemed
to fly in the face of both of those I
think they the pressure which meant
something had to give